As an OB-GYN who specializes
in vulvovaginal disorders,
I hear a lot of myths
about vaginal yeast infections,
and the one that just won't go away
is that they're linked to too much sugar
in your diet.
[Body Stuff with Dr. Jen Gunter]
On the surface, the idea sounds plausible.
After all, sugar is a food source --
not just for us,
but also for yeast and bacteria.
So if we eat more sugar,
we're feeding the yeast.
And there are studies
that show yeast infections
are more common in people with diabetes,
who can have higher levels
of sugar in their blood.
But the truth is,
the sugar consumption-yeast connection
is a myth for most,
perpetuated both by well-meaning
but ill-informed health care professionals
as well as purveyors of snake oil --
you know, the ones
who want to sell you cleanses,
diets and books designed to help you
get rid of all the yeast.
The first thing you need to know
is that yeast is normally
found in the vagina.
At some point in a given year,
one study estimates
that 70 percent of people
will have yeast in their vagina,
just hanging out in the microbiome
and causing no symptoms.
And secondly, sugar is normally
found in the vagina.
After all, that's what also feeds
the good bacteria.
It's the overgrowth of this yeast
that's already there
that produces symptoms
and results in what we call
a yeast infection.
One theory for the sugar-yeast connection
is that the source of the yeast
is actually in the gut,
and that a high-sugar diet
feeds this yeast,
which makes it overgrow,
and then it gets into the vagina.
But there's no credible data
to support this.
Another theory is that eating more sugar
causes sugar levels in the vagina to rise,
thus feeding the yeast.
But it doesn't.
And yes, someone actually studied this.
Researchers gave people,
some with a history
of vaginal yeast infections
and others without,
a drink containing
a lot of sugar or glucose.
Their blood and vaginal sugar levels
were measured before and after the drink.
They found that the sugar levels
in the vaginal secretions didn't change
for either group.
But what about diabetes?
Now we know diabetes is associated
with an increased risk
of vaginal yeast infections,
but the actual reason why isn't known.
While very elevated glucose levels
might be part of it,
it seems the immune system
and other factors
may also be playing a role.
There is a newer class
of diabetes medications
that causes people to dump
a lot of sugar into their urine
as a way to lower blood sugar.
The massive amounts
of sugar in the urine
can cause yeast infections on the vulva
as the vulva is being bathed
in levels of sugar
it didn't evolve to handle.
But unless you have diabetes,
there is no link between eating sugar
and yeast infections.
So ignore the so-called influencers.
It’s fine to enjoy
a slice of cake now and then.
And definitely skip the cleanses.